when you review your life and your mind
do you sit there and go if I told
everyone like I've read Liam Neeson you
dated this one okay there's some people
that have come to the surface they were
always trying to marry me off to like a
prince and you know John John and what
about John John you and John Kennedy
would have been perfect I was so I was
so madly in love with him since the time
I was like three my mom would say that's
the boy
that's the boy you're gonna marry did
you ever as you were older meet John
John I did you did where did the meeting
occur
um Aspen we I was there for a wedding
when you saw him were you like there's
my fantasy there he is and I'm Brooke
Shields and men don't say no to me I
know I it was not that I wish I was that
confident
I really wish I was that confident
instead I was like sure I'll I'll ski
down those Moguls and a black diamond
and never skied before in my life I had
to get had to get ski lifted out because
I I went into the trees I couldn't get
off the mountain and he didn't help me I
was like it's okay he can't help me he's
he's John John it would have been a
moment where the two of you could have
hit it off we did we went out I was
invited with the family
um he kept saying I looked like his
mother which was really interesting and
accomplished but it was also like I
don't know how to feel about this and
then we did have a real date
and
I wouldn't sleep with them
um because I just I kind of loved him
too much where can he take you you're
two of the most famous people in the
world well first we go out to this bar
pub with the rest of his family and so
like everybody's just drinking at the
bar and there's bar fights and drinking
and and he's like you want to get out of
here and I was like ah yeah I do want to
get out of here
yes and I was does he take you in his
car to um we had to take cabs around
everywhere because he didn't have a car
there and we went back to this like
Chalet Hotel that he was in
um like can he he like kissed me and it
was like the best kiss I've ever had in
my life and I was like it was it was not
disappointing oh Beyond not
disappointing just he's just the lips
are beautiful and the face is amazing
and the body and the person and he's
just and he was down to earth and funny
and irreverent you're in the room with
them you kiss him it's the best kiss of
your life I froze though because it was
so precious to me and I was like oh my
God you're falling in love and if you
sleep with them he may not talk to you
again and you can't handle that right
you were you were smart you did the kiss
and then he probably wanted to go right
to SAC absolutely he's like come on
let's go and you're like no no no we're
moving a little fast yeah and I thought
I wasn't playing a game I really was
just I was so afraid of being really
hurt because if I slept with him I would
have given him my entire universe my
heart my everything he never called you
after that again he never said well he I
had to get a cab home
he should have gotten in a car and made
sure you got home already yeah he didn't
have to though he had women falling at
his feet and he didn't have to do
anything for it you know so
I'm on the next day on the slope
and he didn't look at me
and he didn't
talk to me and on the one hand I was
like on the other hand I was like
oh thank God thank God because he still
might not have talked to you even if you
had and you would have given something
that he wouldn't have under like cared
about
and you know what and he and he showed
his two colors in that and yes he did we
got stranded we were all supposed to
leave we got snowed in and he had to
stay in my the house my mom was renting
so then it was my mom and John John and
me in this in this Chalet and and it was
just like this was surreal did he
finally talk to you and say that and I I
think I knew enough about myself by then
you know again I've been doing work on
myself to say you won't be able to
handle this Brooke
thank you